[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie per la fiducia
io non so voi ma questa sigla mi metti
una sentita otto volte mi vien voglia di
invadere voghera comunque comunque
cominciamo dall'inizio io da piccolo
avevo il sogno di diventare un maestro
elementare però i professori della
scuola media consigliano ai miei
genitori
date le mie scarse capacità anti i miei
limiti nelle materie umanistiche di
indirizzarmi verso una scuola tecnica e
infatti sono perito chimico industriale
finita la scuola ah dimenticavo
ironia della sorte siccome non era uno
studente modello
ho superato l'esame di maturità proprio
grazie al tema di italiano appena uscito
dalla scuola ho abbandonato subito
l'idea di trovare lavoro come
dall'industria chimica ma mi sono
trovato catapultato nel mondo
dell'handicap allora così si chiamava
quella vendita ora sono diversamente
abili e prima in maniera precaria poi a
tempo indeterminato sono entrati in un
centro socio educativo per handicappati
dunque handicap è una contrazione di
un'espressione inglese che significa end
in beta cioè la mano che va dare
l'elemosina nel cappello del bisognoso è
un termine che ormai non si usa più come
dicevo è stato superato
resiste solo come insulto c'è una di
cappato non fare landi cappato e nello
sport
immagino che vedrà voi ci siano molti
golfisti quindi questo signore
veramente non a handicap per almeno un
anno in campo sportivo e un percorso
standard di golf per consta di 18 buche
e ad ogni giocatore vengono assegnati
tre colpi nei tornei
semiprofessionistici viene dato alle
persone meno esperte meno capace ai
novizi in modo che possano anche loro
partecipare e migliorare il loro
handicap o un bottino di colpi in più
quindi un bel gruzzolo di colpi per
superare uno svantaggio e partendo da
questa considerazione il mio percorso
non è stato nel dolce come potete
immaginare va appunto nell'handicap ho
cominciato a lavorare
il primo di aprile se le date vogliono
dire qualcosa
sono entrato in questo centro è la mia
prima impressione è stata qui sono tutti
matti io non ci vengo più ci sono
rimasto 17 anni
la mansione era educatore quindi una
specie di maestro tutto ritorna
contemporaneamente la mia passione mi ha
portato una delle mie passioni mi ha
portato a frequentare un corso triennale
di teatro in cui mi sono diplomato
attore loro avendo queste due cose in ma
non il lavoro come educatore e questo
disturbo ma di attore ho pensato ma
perché non proviamo a unire queste cose
perché non proviamo a passi che un
attività del centro socio educativo non
sia il laboratorio teatrale
a quel punto bisognava in qualche modo
far sì che questo laboratorio
presentasse qualcosa di terapeutico cioè
che i partecipanti al laboratorio
in questa attività potenziasse le loro
abilità residue migliorasse delle loro
capacità relazionali e di comunicazione
insomma praticamente che migliorasse la
loro qualità di vita
io avevo un'esperienza appunto sulla
disabilità maturata in quegli anni e poi
avevo la mia esperienza teatrale
maturata dalla scuola di teatro dalla
conoscenza del teatro di ricerca che
interessava molto ma soprattutto da quel
bagaglio infinito che era l'animazione
teatrale con gli iscritti e gli esempi
di gianni rodari di franco passatore e
di giuliano scabia che aveva affiancato
franco basaglia nelle esperienze
dell'ospedale psichiatrico di trieste
bene tutto questo poteva andare bene per
quanto riguarda diciamo il laboratorio
dove si trovava così però visto che noi
volevamo fare degli spettacoli a
renderci visibili
ci chiedevamo come fare cioè quali
spettacoli fare quale forma dare al
nostro stare sul palcoscenico il
palcoscenico ha dei limiti i
partecipanti allo striano dei limiti il
pubblico ai dei limiti allora ragionando
su questo abbiamo cominciato a produrre
si degli spettacoli ci siamo ispirati
alla fiaba principalmente come struttura
narrativa però sentivamo che c'era
comunque qualcosa che non andava
non so se avete presente quando uno
indossa un abito che non è suo
che fatica ad abituarsi insomma non era
era come usando un esempio calcistico
era come se noi volessimo fare il gioco
della juventus degli anni 80
tardelli rossi fratini insomma essendo
il verona dei primi anni di bagnoli
insomma era un'impresa difficilissima
bisognava cambiare qualche cosa è
trovare un nuovo punto di partenza
ed è proprio qui
che interviene la grazia bislacca
durante un corso di formazione ebbe la
fortuna di incontrare denise gaitan era
uno psicoterapeuta ea perché purtroppo
non c'è più
musicologo musicoterapeuta musicista
africa tra tutto lui insomma era una
figura è estremamente di valore e
conduceva un'esperienza interessante con
un gruppo questi chiamava la stravaganza
di cui verrà il maestro il maestro di
cerimonia e con questi ragazzi mettevano
in scena delle opere liriche da quattro
soldi come diceva lui dove dei portatori
di svantaggio psicofisico e psichiatrico
stavano sul palco facendo vedere
guardate lui definiti con un'immagine la
grazia bislacca ora capisco che così non
è ancora quindi per chi volesse avere
delle informazioni sulla grazie misurata
l'anno scorso abbiamo avuto la fortuna
che è una studentessa del corso di
laurea di riabilitazione psichiatrica ha
prodotto una tesi sul nostro laboratorio
è questa io siccome sono vanitoso come
un torero faccio vedere le cose che
riguardano noi ha prodotto questo questa
tesi e
e poi è diventata anche attrice del
laboratorio
questo per quanto riguarda la teoria di
ci sono le idee da dov'è nato insomma
tutte queste cose qua invece c'è il
prototipo papa tanta tanta tanta beh
comunque una qualsiasi canzone in
quattro parti va bene perché l'hanno
fatto in diversi
concentriamoci stadio e olio dicevamo no
abbiamo visto cento volte concentriamoci
sulla figura di di olio oliver hardy era
un signore alto un metro e 83 pesava 120
kg quindi un corpo non propriamente
portato per la danza è visto così poteva
sembrare in effetti condannato a questa
presenza massiccia
pesante invece e invece cosa succede
oliver hardy trascende va oltre
va oltre il suo stesso corpo vedete è
leggero grazioso aggraziate alla grazia
bislacca persona invitata è quello e
questa grazia ci ha insegnato come può
essere divertente la vita ea come noi
possiamo essere delle persone
meravigliose ma non solo questo ci ha
lasciato a denise light ha una cosa in
più profonda
partivamo da questo presupposto poco fa
il teatro terapeutico all'handicap e lo
disse ma perché non proviamo a fare
questa operazione
ma cosa semplice perché non possiamo
pensare a quanto len dica possa essere
terapeutico al teatro nel senso di
quanto lavorare con queste persone sia
davvero frequentare le persone che si
fanno fiorire come aveva accennato prima
la nostra conduttrice
perché non usare quello che possono
darci per dare un po una scrollata al
teatro allora nel teatro è abbastanza
convenzionale insomma avanti ora ci sono
delle esperienze interessanti ma quello
che viene proposto e molto cominciare
quindi questo dava la possibilità quindi
erano loro i ragazzi che davano la
possibilità noi teatranti di portare sul
palco un mondo poetico nuovo detto di
tentare una via diversa che tenesse
conto del sogno della visione ed è
quello che abbiamo cercato di fare
eccoci e questi siamo noi
dunque allora da lì abbiamo cominciato a
cambiare
vi faccio un esempio stavamo allestendo
con il primo gruppo che avevo aspettando
godot di samuel beckett presa
pensavamo comunque e pensavo che quel
mondo fosse abbastanza parente del mondo
dei nostri ragazzi e stava molestando
questa scena con due ragazzi due ragazzi
down loredana e alberto loredana doveva
dire come sto alberto orrenda e lei non
più di ieri battuta da testo così
insegniamo copione capito la battuta si
va bene entra
loredana come sto alberto orrenda ma mi
ha detto orrenda
e noi no assicurarsi loredana questo è
il copione sono le battute che devi dire
dai prova riproviamo come sto è orrenda
basta vivo via e andava via
allora riprendere riporta rispiego
un'altra volta
ok pronti come sto io non glielo devo
più orrenda però s'arrabbia allora a
questo punto avevamo tre strade o non
farla o insistere ancora accanirsi su
questa cosa
oppure lasciarla così com'era
abbiamo lasciata così com'era il nostro
spettacolo in quella scena ma anche in
altre cosa che volevamo si adattava a
loro si adattava alle loro piccole crepe
a queste loro in precisione ci dava la
possibilità di tentare dell'altro ti
dava la possibilità di scoprire delle
vie creative magari mai pensate
soprattutto dava anche la possibilità al
pubblico che ci osservava di rivedere un
po le proprie categorie mentali perché
allora se voglio parlare comunque siamo
a fine anni 80 e così il concetto di
disabilità era un po quindi poi messa in
scena ancora era abbastanza difficile
il commento migliore che ci arrivava era
è stato bello ho pianto tanto ma
sembrava solo farci un grande commozione
l'altro più crudele era per essere
handicappati hanno fatto fin troppo
e questo che sicuro sarà così
noi non vogliamo della commozione a buon
mercato non ci interessa noi vorremmo
essere trattati come artisti un atto di
presunzione però vogliamo che i nostri
spettacoli vengano visti come come gli
spettacoli di tutti vogliamo essere sì
sorprendenti bizzarri imprecisi con la
nostra grazie a bislacca vogliamo avere
degli spettatori perplessi come diceva
il mio amico bertold brecht l'arte
divide la vera arte di leader
non è che però è questo meglio essere un
po cialtroni e meglio essere un po
grotteschi piuttosto che essere
irrimediabilmente noiosi e quello che
vogliamo fare quando facciamo gli
spettacoli e portare qui sul palco mondo
di cui ci si possa innamorare e che
lasci spazio al sogno lasciare spazio al
sogno incontri sono importanti
un'altra persona che ho incontrato enzo
toma che ha un regista del teatro kismet
di bari e durante un soccorso e ha fatto
questo esempio ora lo vedete da questo
libro si è fatto non capiva va bene
anche lui si muoveva su questo
territorio allora fatto così ha chiesto
disegnato una mano il più vero del vero
fatene il contorno mettete tutte le
rughe se avete degli anelli tutto quello
che già sono a mano poi la stessa
persona viene invitata a disegnarla con
gli occhi bendati sentiamo nel confronto
ora vediamo da una parte è il più vero
del vero il real è quello che vediamo
tutti i giorni quello che ci sforziamo
era un po di lavoro che facevamo gli
inizi adattarci a una cosa che non era
nostra l'altro invece è il luogo della
mente luogo del sogno
guardiamo lo più da vicino perché è
sempre la stessa mano è la stessa
identità identiche la stessa mano però
magari c'è uno che ride
magari c'è uno che ha la frangetta gli
occhi chiusi magari c'è uno che è un po
corrucciato e magari oliver hardy ci
saluta dall'altra parte è questo no
questo non era questo il sogno è qui ora
questo percorso
dopo averlo fatto con un centro socio
educativo che dicevo si è materializzato
si è reso più cosa alla fondazione
adolescere di voghera che devo citare
per forza e con piacere perché ci sono
da 16 anni dice trovato una condizione
fondamentale la fiducia la fiducia
dell'istituzione la fiducia degli
operatori perché queste cose non si
fanno da soli e la fiducia dei ragazzi
essenzialmente e poi una cosa
particolare all'interno di questo centro
c'è un teatro piccolino che è diventata
la nostra casa è il nostro luogo intimo
al nostro logo protetto
qual è per voi qual è il vostro posto
dove state bene estate a casa
non dico le vostre case le vostre
famiglie questo è un altro discorso ma
il vostro luogo più intimo dove state
bene però ieri e il teatro dove stanno i
nostri non so dove vengono abbracciati
dove i nostri limiti le nostre crepe
sono prese diventano caratteristiche e
si aprono una finestra verso
l'autenticità per regalarci una stupita
meraviglia quello che facciamo
oltre l'arte speriamo vi sul palco è
quello di valere per una sera siamo noi
siamo qui valiamo
ed è un grosso riscontro per la comunità
per i genitori di questi ragazzi per gli
amici per la fondazione per il pubblico
che c'è per una volta queste persone che
sono abituate ad essere trattate come ho
viste
oggetto di cura oggetto di scherno
oggetto di stigma oggetto di compassione
diventano soggetti dello scambio sociale
per quella volta siamo noi e per quella
volta e questo lo devo farvi vedere lo
spettacolo ma noi li buttiamo fra due
giorni a voghera teatro san rocco
allora vi faccio vedere come prendono
gli applausi a teatro o prendere gli
applausi è il clichè è la gigioneria
dell'attore ce lo insegnano scuola di
teatro come si fa a prendere gli
applausi 36 secondi si fanno uscire
composti salutare salutare qualcuno
saluta liliana non si capisce perché poi
si saluta la in fondo si lite mentre
loro tutto questo ci abbiamo provato
dopo un po più andato allenate dal coach
riuscire composti
no loro li esprimono la loro gioia di
essere linee di fare di questa serata
una serata memorabile dove c'è la
felicità di esservi di essere
riconosciuti come qualcosa che variano
sono così nella londra di chiara tezza
uno va sono favoriti ma in qualche modo
uno salta che non deve saltare in quel
caso eccoli arriva vedere si sente di
prendere la mano e poi tir in vita un
altro quello intero così e questo no
e nel momento degli applausi è il
momento più vero di questa comunicazione
ho finito grazie
[Applauso]